boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakyan we
are still on site in manhattan in new
york city new york we are now going to
be talking about all things race
gender we're going to be talking about
universities diversity
school system the foundation of truth
and we have heather mcdonald joining us
hello hi ellen thank you for having me
thank you for coming on to the show
again we did a skype call for the first
time but we're really excited to have
this chance in person to talk to you a
little bit of background on heather
heather is a scholar in race relations
immigration policing colleges
universities she's a senior fellow at
the manhattan institute contributing
editor at city journal and she's the
author of the war on cops the burden of
bad ideas and most recently the
diversity delusion
how race and gender pandering corrupt
the university and undermine our culture
so
i'm really excited to be talking about
this
this is a pressing topic the foundation
of truth is extremely important and we
want to understand the nuance of what's
going on here
so let's talk about things on like a big
history perspective because
we find ourselves
as stewards of earth as humans and
we are trying to figure things out
population's been hockey sticking up we
now have all 7.7 billion people
we are
facing
exponential technologies across every
single industry
we
really need to be building up this
foundation of truth what is your what
are your thoughts on the current state
of humanity
well i it's hard for me to address the
entire globe but i can tell you what's
going on in the west
which is a concerted attack
on enlightenment notions of reason
of objectivity
of the search for truth
and a
effort to return us to a tribal
mentality that is destructive and
a source of inequality ignorance and
violence
we've been
playing with fire i would say in the
west for the last 50 years or so
in cultivating re-cultivating
tribal hatreds that
was one of the great triumphs
of the western nation state
to overcome the pettiness of tribe
versus tribe
and also one of the triumphs of the
enlightenment to say that human beings
possess a capacity for reason
that is not limited
by
ethnicity or nationality but is
something that all human beings can
aspire to
whoa okay we have a lot of
gratitude to give to
a lot of what the west
has achieved in the last several hundred
years the united states in just the last
240 years has
went from
went from
13
colonies to 50 states across spanning
from sea to shining sea and we have a
tremendously high standard of living now
there's a lot that the individual in
capitalism has actually accomplished in
raising the baseline of living for a lot
of people around the world and
at the same time there are some ways to
potentially figure out how to
ray dalio and warren buffett have said
yeah we've we've definitely bill gates
as well have said that we've taken we've
actually got a lot of success out of
capitalism but now it's time for us to
somehow restructure and return
things back to raising the baseline up
so it's kind of we're still figuring out
how to best
move forward in maybe like a capitalism
2.0 or whatever with exponential
technology um
heather you you know you're really a
strong advocate for these western
principles and ideals that have built
this
civilization that we're typically not so
aware of tell us about those principles
and ideals
well i think uh
the the west has been the source of the
concept of individual rights
of human dignity
that is
universal
rather than limited to a clan
and
those ideals of universal rights
are simply foreign to
cultures today i mean it's really quite
astounding
that
left-wing academics
spend all of their time
directing their ire against what i would
say is phantom
misogyny and patriarchy let's say
in the west
when females here are the freest they've
ever been in human history
there's not a single barrier that i've
ever faced in my life and i do not think
i'm idiosyncratic
in other parts of the world
females
are still
whipped in public
for not covering their bodies
in rural nepal
females who are menstruating have to
occupy
huts
away from their families because they're
viewed as unclean
just recently
the new york times reported on another
female from saudi arabia who
escaped
to try and live a freer life in the west
away from the
misogyny that characterizes
many muslim countries today
good luck staging a gay pride march in
uganda
you know malaysia parts of indonesia
are still flogging homosexuals egypt is
about to recriminalize homosexuality
so
the blindness of
of
the
whole diversity bureaucracy
to the
enormous differences in freedom
personal liberty
uh between the west and
third world countries is simply stunning
and and what we enjoy here today
is the product of a philosophical
tradition
that dates at least to periclean athens
and the
the
use of reason to try and interrogate
human
assumptions that we see in the the
platonic dialogues
the extraordinary philosophical
tradition that came out of plato and
aristotle moving through the middle ages
uh obviously taking a big detour in
in metaphysics and theology but
but
pressing ahead still
with a reverence for learning
and and again for me the high point in
sending us to this current path of
extraordinary abundance is the
enlightenment ideals uh
we had the growth of empiricism in the
renaissance with francis bacon
saying that
you know we need a natural science that
is going to try and
use
reason to unlock the mysteries of nature
all of these things are
extraordinary and and have given us
freedom from want from disease that was
would have been unthinkable a mere 300
years ago
and
this is
a tremendous progress that we've now
mentioned several times needs to come
with more gratitude to the people that
got us here and to the economic and
political systems that helped us get
here and the greater that we can
identify that and really give our our
empathy and our gratitude for that the
more we can really connect with the
abundance that we truly have now and you
actually even when pointed out that this
is not just a single um country in one
part of the world that still has issues
with um treating
women or people that just think
differently than than they do of um
poorly you actually said this is in in
indonesia still in parts of asia parts
of the middle east parts of africa this
this extends
um past
past just one isolated instance still
going on around the world and
in order to raise the baseline of of
acceptance of tolerance of
of
of love and compassion for each other we
it's really important to build on this
foundation of science that came from
this period of the enlightenment this
foundation of truth
and
a lot of what is our university system
our collegiate system is supposed to be
the cutting edge of truth
that's how we that's how we're supposed
to be building children at studying that
cutting edge in whatever discipline
they're seeking to study but there's
this new sort of bureaucracy that's come
into play the diversity bureaucracy and
you list so many examples in the book
across different collegiate campuses
that where the diversity bureaucracy is
now taking millions of dollars
multi-million dollar bureaucracy and
there's a certain aspect to this which
which is which is that we we consider
okay now
now
does somebody come from well first let's
start before we get into these examples
does um tell us about the the diversity
bureaucracy and what that's doing to the
foundation of truth in
in the university system well the
diversity bureaucracy is just a
grotesque waste of resources if you want
to know why college tuition is so
obscenely expensive look no further than
these metastasizing cinecures
the
the vice chancellor for equity diversity
and inclusion at ucla the university of
california los angeles uh averages over
four hundred thousand dollars a year for
absolutely nothing
uh
these these bureaucracies are premised
on the idea that colleges are
lethally sexist and racist that students
of color and females are literally at
threat of their lives on a college
campus this is a complete insane
narcissistic delusion there has never
been an environment more tolerant
of precisely those traits that can still
get you
stoned or killed in other parts of the
world
than today's american college campus
so these diversity bureaucrats
who are multiplying at an alarming rate
are dedicated to a fiction and they are
cultivating in students
ever more arcane
species of self-involvement to think of
themselves at at risk to think of
themselves as victims of racism and
sexism whereas in fact they are the most
privileged human beings in history
because they have at their fingertips
the thing that faust sold his soul for
which is knowledge
uh they are surrounded by caring
open-minded liberal adults who want all
of their students to succeed
they the faculty
every single faculty search at a college
campus is one desperate effort to find
remotely qualified females and and
faculty of color who've not been
snatched up already by better endowed
institutions and far from discriminating
against
so-called underrepresented minorities in
student admissions that is blacks and
hispanics virtually every selective
college today employs vast racial
preferences
to admit underrepresented minorities so
the idea that colleges are infected by
systemic bias is a complete untruth and
yet
that is the premise of these
bureaucracies but
as
as much as these bureaucracies deserve
to be condemned and extirpated root and
branch
they are just part of an entire ideology
of victimhood that exists throughout the
faculty
it's not just the bureaucrats
they uh large swaths of the faculty are
also devoted to cultivating this idea
that the west is
uniquely the source of
all things evil in the world bigotry
sexism patriarchy rape culture you name
it
and so you've got a double whammy there
where from the moment a student steps on
campus his freshman orientation is
inevitably going to
feature little seminars in white
privilege and toxic masculinity
uh his residential advisors the the
students who are supposed to be
you know overseeing dormitory life
uh they are inevitably wildly lefty
uh and and in classes
all too often students are taught to
read
the greatest works of western
civilization
through the lens of racial and gender
victimology
there's a lot of scientific
valid
evidence to take from these works and
really powerful stories to take from
these works and not just
push them to the side because they were
written by someone
it's insane it's absolutely insane i am
so grateful that i was in college in the
1970s before
feminism and multiculturalism attacked
the canon
so while i wasted vast amounts of time
trying to
master a
particularly arcane literary theory
called deconstruction or
post-structuralism
something that i now regard as a dead
end intellectually nevertheless
we were reading
the greatest works without anybody
thinking to complain about the gonads
and melanin of their authors so my
freshman year
in my major english poet's class
i read
chaucer
spencer edmund spencer's fairy queen
milton's paradise lost wordsworth
wallace stevens
the romantic poets shelley
keats
and
my ears were filled with beauty with the
beauty of milton's comas the
extraordinarily erotic
sensual writing
of book four of paradise lost
and
i i wasn't given an excuse to reject
these works simply because they weren't
written by a female i can think of
nothing less relevant
to whether a book is worth reading
than the race and gender of its author
yeah the the the message of the writing
as you read it
whether or not you know the gonads or
the melanin of the author is the most
important thing is what you can actually
take from the writing
and i think that's super important to to
start seeing things in that light
because that way there's like you have
said also there's science is science if
you it doesn't matter what your skin
color or religion or race is
gender is just contribute to science
yeah there's no yeah there's no
um female physics there's no there's
none of that just contribute to science
to that foundation well you're speaking
now idealistically and of course
now
well we've we
since the 1980s at least we heard about
multicultural math and there was in fact
for k through 12 this idea that math
should be somehow
taught
to try and close the skills gap with
blacks and whites
in some kind of black way
that was specious back then
and it remains specious today but but
yes what
our greatest risk we're facing now
is that
the
stem departments and universities that
is the science technology engineering
and math
are now being invaded by this
absurd diversity ideology and you have
department after department saying
we're not going to hire the best
scientist we're going to hire the best
female scientist or the best black
scientist that shouldn't matter
you have the national science foundation
which is the nation's premier funder of
basic research it's a
government agency created by congress in
1950
to support
non-applied research in the science
and it now
is committed to the diversity ideology
it argues that the only good science is
diverse science
it's ridiculous i don't care if the lab
that finally breaks through on on the
causes and cures for alzheimer's is all
female all male all asian or all
jamaican i don't care
it's a universal language they should be
the best
and china in the sciences at least
remains committed
to meritocratic hiring
if we continue down this path of putting
excellence
below
some kind of gender and race
proportionality in our science labs and
hiring we are going to lose our our
competitive edge and this is a
destructive point of view that is not
limited to university campuses it's also
in the private sector now where you have
the big silicon valley tech firms
firing people if they challenge feminist
orthodoxy there's a lawsuit that's been
filed against youtube and google
by a former
manager in the hr department who refused
to go along with the mandate
to interview only
females blacks and hispanics for
entry-level engineering jobs
so
these
google and youtube were willing to turn
their backs on what may be
the best engineering talent if that
talent was white male or asian
this is reckless to say the least
there's so many ways to to go with this
i want to
i'm glad you mentioned corporations and
the way that the product from the
university ends up then coming into the
corporate environments and continuing
that this type of behavior into the
corporate environment
so okay so we start we want to start by
talking about stem because
this is one of the most important fields
for our future across the world is
figuring out how to properly engineer
and design the future technologies that
are going to be influencing the
exponential technology
next couple of decades so we want to be
at the forefront we want our children to
be at the forefront children around the
world we want to be at the forefront and
we
we see here isn't it here's here's an
issue here's a way to frame the issue
that i think makes it relatable across
people's minds is that we've never
wanted
50 of the military to be female
it's just a nonsensical statement
if only that were the case sorry yeah i
mean
you're you're operating from a position
of rationality
uh
in fact we
the military now has been overtaken by
gender politics as well
i've always said we're never gonna have
a female in the nfl because americans
understand that football is important
but we now
have the preposterous idea of females in
infantry ground combat units which is
just completely blind to the inherent
differences between male and female the
structure of their pelvises bone
structure muscle structure as well as to
the inevitable introduction of arrows
and its disruption to combat
unit cohesion
of having
integrated ground combat unit uh it's
it's it's absolutely preposterous uh so
no there's
that the military is not free from this
in fact it has now massive diversity
bureaucracy it has gender quotas
everywhere
uh and everybody's uh being packed off
to implicit bias training and
microaggression training so
your your presupposition
was uh an understandable one but i'm
afraid you're behind the times alan
yeah and
just to take that again in another
hopefully relatable way is that
men
there's no there's no lobby for there to
be
50
of men in nursing good well exactly i
mean it's an interesting
asymmetry
any disparity that favors females is
regarded as natural nobody complains
obstetrics gyn
5 83
of ob gyns are are female now
uh nobody says well there must be
anti-male bias
but anything less than 50 50
proportionality male female if there's
less females is
inevitably and
irrevocably uh attributed to
anti-female bias
the females now dominate in the
university they dominate the student
body they're vast way over the majority
of
of
male students
they dominate in the administration they
dominate in humanities and social
science fields again that's all seen as
perfectly fine
but
let there be any field
that is
gender neutral gender blind that
nevertheless for a variety of reasons
that we can go into uh does not have 50
50 that is only explainable by bias
yeah that that mentality itself is
non-multivariate it's unidimensional
it's just looking at one thing and
seeing it as oh it's
it's discrimination
and when there's thousands millions of
variables to actually calculate to be
able to understand things
so
so we must then
maximize the equality of opportunity for
everyone on the planet as quickly as we
can to where people can pursue whatever
they find most meaningful or interesting
but not forcibly
put people into 50 50 divides across all
these sub-identity categories so just
pursue what you find most meaningful and
will and everyone on the planet will
hopefully have that equality of
opportunity um very soon we've been
doing a good job as we indicated in the
first portion of getting people up to
that to that state well it's very
interesting because there's something
called the equality index it turns out
that
females in the most gender equal
societies which are
basically the northern european
societies rate the highest
they have
the lowest rate of going into stem
fields
the more options females have the more
they go towards their natural
inclinations which is towards more
human-centered hands-on relational work
work that is traditionally viewed as
having
you know changing the world for the
better social meaning yeah
i happen to disagree that being a
computer coder does not have social
meaning or does not change the world
better but but the traditional way is
you know being a social worker or
uh
you know the
certain aspects of the healthcare system
and
it's in places where females have less
freedom where they have higher rates of
going into stem
so this isn't to say of course that
there are not individual females that
are every bit as
uh abstractly driven for for to master
abstract fields as males
we're talking averages here
uh and that is one explanation
for why there's not 50 50 parity in stem
other explanations are
the
different distribution of the the
variance of high-end and low-end math
skills
it turns out that at the very low end of
math cluelessness
males predominate
they're the the worst math dummies and
at the very high high end
of math skills
males predominate
again there's there's always
exceptions to this but in the united
states
for every
2.5 males at the .01
percentage
of math genius
for every 2.5 males there's one female
another distinction is
females with high-end math skills tend
to also have
very good verbal skills
giving them more career options the ma
the males with the very high-end
math skills are not as good verbally so
they are sort of forced to go into
a uh
sort of geeky field
so we're identifying again just so many
variables that go into this calculation
it's not just unit dimensional so
i want to also make sure that we come to
what you initially said in that segment
where you where you started identifying
that um
the the youth that are going to these
young adults that are entering into the
collegiate systems actually have the
most the least bigotry ever ever on
collegiate campuses there's nobody that
is trying to withhold their voting
rights or trying to withhold um uh
rights to enter into any sort of
establishments of any sort
that the the the quality of of emotional
care and presence and lack of hatred
that is available there at the
universities with the professors with
the counselors with the peers pure
networks there is just high it's the
highest you're absolutely right again
the faculty
are
liberal they want all of their students
to succeed in particular
females and so-called underrepresented
minorities there are no barriers
the students have access to libraries
that would have driven the renaissance
humanists mad with envy and desire
they can read every book that has ever
been written
this is just an unbelievable
treasure
you can walk into the library nobody is
holding you back
and yet
females and so-called students of color
are being taught
by the diversity bureaucrats and by far
too many professors
to see blocks and they're being given a
chip on their shoulder
rather than being given an adult
perspective on their
enormous privilege
they are being taught to see barriers
where none exist and that chip on their
shoulder follows them into the
non-academic world after they graduate
and prevents them from seizing the
boundless opportunities that are
available to them
yes okay there's
i want to enter that subject and i want
to also mention how the there is some
sort of an issue with the way that you
know as jonathan hyde points out that
we're just
coddling the mind from the youth and
we're not letting an immune system build
up and if we're not letting the kids
face adversity ever then they're not
going to be prepared they're going to
want to flag every microaggression as
some sort of an issue that needs to be
dealt with at a at a governmental or
political level of sorts instead of
approaching it as something that they
can overcome that hey like you know
why did you like why did you say that or
let's talk about this let's have a civil
discourse let's grow and evolve our
ethics together is now out the window
it's reporting and flagging people and
getting a boost from doing that
which is very strange and then you
started um indicating at the at the end
of the of the segment the the the goal
the mentality of setting goals and
achieving goals is now taking a back
seat to talking about
how i've suffered in my life
and
it's unfortunate because the people that
actually suffered are the ones that the
hundred billion people that lived and
died before us that suffered poor
electricity and running water and food
ubiquity and and that didn't have
penicillin that couldn't fly around in
airplanes around the world these are the
people that suffered right yeah
it's absolutely true it's absolutely
true i i could not agree more i i
respect jonathan hates in hunting
enormously i respect his heterodox
academy in norfolk this is an extremely
vital institution nevertheless i have
taken issue with his analysis of what's
going on he does see
the
uh college hysteria as primarily a
psychological phenomenon one of
over-parenting helicopter parents
coddling of students
i see it as an ideological one
the the demographics don't quite work
out
because
it is not the case sadly that on average
uh black and hispanic kids are over
parented there may be some in the elites
that are some parents there that are
mimicking the same parenting behaviors
as as
white parents and asians to a lesser
degree
but the problem mostly with black and
hispanic kids is they don't not have
adequate parenting
it's it's a completely different
parenting style when
leaving aside the question of whether
there's two parents at home at all
also
uh
the
the brothers you talk about the out of
wedlock births and that causing a major
issue towards violence and tolerance
yeah no they're out of the breakdown of
the of the family is the biggest social
catastrophe we face today but
the other thing that does not match up
demographically with the hate over
parenting thesis
is that the brothers of these white
female students on campus
who are
going around
yowling about being in a patriarchy in
rape culture
their brothers are not by and large
demanding safe spaces but they have the
same helicopter parents
so
this is really an ideological farm that
that tells certain chosen
anointed victim groups to think of
themselves as victims
and the others who do not fall within
that category are by definition
oppressors unless they can work
themselves out of the oppressor category
by
becoming a quote ally which is a
ridiculously
sort of melodramatic term
allies are something you need in war
and indeed that's the reigning conceit
on college campuses which is to be a
female or a so-called student of color
which does not include asians
is to be at war at literally at risk of
your life from circumambient racism and
sexism
but as far as the resilience argument
and i mean i agree with that that
that
adults have a responsibility
to teach students
perspective and while i don't think
there's any ground for calling anything
on a college campus an adversity
so these microaggressions being asked
say well so like what are you which is a
frequent microaggression that gets put
up on these little student videos about
how oppressed they are
this is in a context of say a freshman
mixer and somebody is saying like well
what is like your ethnic heritage that
is now seen as a microaggression
in a world where we're told that the
most important thing
about somebody is his ethnic racial
identity so this question is perfectly
legit within that
discourse
being told that that is a
microaggression is not a way to
use your time
productively you know
an adult should tell people the
difference between a real problem
and a
fake problem
being asked what is what are you is a
fake problem a real problem is being
shot at having malaria with no cure
having tuberculosis with no cure
not having clean water not having clean
food
child birth leading inevitably to
50 mortality of women of mothers and
children those are problems
not microaggressions
it's very strongly put and i would agree
with you that those are real problems
that society faces
and they are used to facing they used
that used to face yeah and we and we
broke our way through the
those problems by banding together and
and and being entrepreneurs and being um
following principles of of of of
capitalism and raising the baseline
baseline of living for people and i
really appreciated the way that you um
made a difference between what is what
is written in the coddling in the sense
that there is this is more of an
ideology like you said
um
i think that is actually quite quite
accurate it's it's very
it's very
it's it's
it's concerning to see
massive groups of people that are
just shutting down
conversations that oppose their
viewpoints on college campuses including
conversations
speeches that you've
given
that we need a deeper dis uh desire for
discourse just as simple as um heather
why don't we go through a thought
experiment we can even go through a
thought experiment right now that i
think might
might help potentially
so
you know i like to run simulations in my
mind and um a simulation that we could
potentially run is
that
what if society evolved where the
the role of of of white and black was
swapped so as though the black was the
one that ended up capturing white and
enslaving white um by the
tens of millions um in the um 1800s
let's just say that as an example um and
then
and then there was the transgenerational
period of trauma that occurred from that
process
that
we would also feel then us a a bit of of
of of trauma as well a bit of just of of
like wow that was really painful and
seeing you know a majority of you know
44 of the presidents um being black
let's say and only one being white and
and so etc and so when we go through
this simulation of of an experiment of
what that would be like i start to feel
better what it may feel like to be
black today
but also
i realized that
i need to move forward and i need to
have goals moving forward away from just
bathing myself in the trauma of the past
and wanting to move forward what do you
think about that thought experiment well
sure that's a valid thought experiment i
think
again the question is what is the most
efficacious way now
to close
the racial gap and what more
can let's return to reality
whites do to close it is it is is what
we're seeing today
predominantly
with the academic skills gap which is
huge the average black 12th grader
reads at the level of the average white
8th grader
there still is a poverty gap but that is
overwhelmingly explained by blacks 71
percent
out of wedlock birth rate
uh that that's the greatest factor in
determining child poverty today is
whether you have a single parent or two
married parents
so
what is the best way to close that
achievement gap and
there's no question
that this country
lived in grotesque
violation of its founding ideals for 200
years 200 plus years blind to the
hypocrisy it's it's unthinkable today i
mean how could this not have been so
obvious
that we had created a racial caste
system which was completely at odds with
declaration of independence and what we
purported to stand for
so that is all true
and one can understand the lingering
anger
and resentment that it creates but
i would argue that today
barriers have fallen in every mainstream
institution i do not know a single
mainstream institution that is not
trying to
hire and promote as many blacks as
possible whether it's corporations banks
law firms the media hollywood
uh foundations universities
publishing houses you name it it is an
obsession
it is an obsession
and
we have had
compensatory policies for a long time
we've had welfare redistribution of
wealth
at this point i would say that the
biggest
divide between liberals and
conservatives in their world view
is that
a liberal
will see
structural forces as the predominant
explanation for
any type of inequality
a conservative is more likely to see
individual behavioral choices
so i'll put out another thought
experiment to you
let's have
blacks act like asians
for 10 years in everything relevant
to achieving
worldly success
so rather than a 71 percent out of
wedlock birth rate they have a 16 out of
wedlock birth rate asians the vast
majority of kids are growing up in two
parent families
rather than a anti-white
anti-acting white culture
that demeans academic effort as acting
white
and stigmatizes students black students
black peers who are seen as caring too
much about doing homework how about if
blacks emulate asians fanatical
attention to academic success how about
parents emulate asian parents
overwhelming interest in whether their
students their children are studying
whether they're acing their exams their
refusal to accept anything short of an a
something that was also and still is
characteristic of many jewish parents
which explains why
until asians leapt out ahead jews were
the most academically successful group
now asians are whooping everybody's ass
and how about if blacks also emulate
asians in their negligible crime rates
right now the homicide rate for blacks
is eight times higher than whites and
hispanics combined asians don't even
show up
on those crime rates uh
how about blacks emulate asians in
school attendance absence of truancy
waiting until you're married to have
children
graduating from college
if after 10 years of acting like asians
in all things relevant
to economic success
we still saw
economic disparities
i would then
be
very willing to entertain racism
as the explanation
but when the behavioral disparities are
so great
right now in california say the black
truancy rate is five times the net the
state average
uh talk to stu teachers in inner city
schools who will tell you about the
difficulty of maintaining discipline
a difficulty of getting students to just
take their textbooks home to study
when those behavioral disparities remain
as large as they are
i'm not willing to say structural
explanations are the most important
thing so there's a professor at the
university of pennsylvania that was a
really good simulation okay that was a
really good simulation because you
really think about it for a period of
time it's what would you want to change
in the behavior patterns in order to
maximize the potential of the children
of that demographic and that was a
really good simulation if if we had a a
massive experiment where we could see
what would happen for 10 years with
black people adapting these traits of
asians that you that you indicated
i bet there would be a
big
roaring success that would come from
that and um
so that was really powerful heather i'm
happy you ran that simulation and that's
that's that's why this show is called
simulation is because we like to do
these thought experiments of how
societies can evolve and how they can
become better by taking on these
potential changes in behavior
and seeing where that can go in the
future
well there's one thing specifically that
you said there's a difference in seeing
things that i thought was interesting
it was that
when we when we see a hierarchy that has
evolved um
that you made it you made an interesting
point that it can be that
at some times that liberals may see it
as the structural violences that are in
place that are causing oppression and
tyranny and conservatives can see it as
in some ways as individual behaviors of
people causing them to either go up in
the hierarchy or down in the hierarchy
and this hierarchy is based on
socioeconomics let's say but there's
also hierarchies based on like spiritual
actualization or all all different other
types of um of potential ways to sort um
humans but
i thought that was a cool point because
it's kind of it we kind of have to find
a nuanced ground in between those in the
sense that it's totally on the behavior
of individuals to figure them their way
up um in in the world but also it's
about figuring out what are the last
violences and the structures that are
left that make it difficult for people
to rise up and help eradicate those but
there seems to be too big of a megaphone
identifying that for something that's so
little and your behavior is actually
worth way more your mind the way your
mind thinks is way more important than
your melanin or gonads right well that's
true and
you know it
it's difficult thing to say to somebody
uh
overcome adversity
it just seems like well what right do
you have to say that but
but it is the case that
those
extraordinary
civil rights pioneers
uh
struggled against adversity and
succeeded it's does not think we don't
want to wish that on anybody
but it is a much better
mindset as you say
to think of oneself as having the power
to overcome obstacles
rather than to
see every obstacle real or imagined as
something that must set you back
and and block any further progress
so
there's been pioneers in many fields
there's always a first person i can't
stand this idea that you can only
succeed if you have a role model that
matches your gonads or melanin
you know how did marie curie learn to
you know conquer the secrets of of
radiation she was the first female
scientist in that field what mattered to
her was the joy of discovery
and i don't need some female
to tell me if i wanted to do chemistry
that that i i can only do it if there's
females that have gone before me that
creates a vicious cycle where if there's
nobody in a field then there will never
be anybody in that field because the
assumption is you can only follow
somebody else before you that's
ridiculous
so see it be it helps
but it's not a necessity for discovery
it's that curiosity that inherent
curiosity yeah ideas do are not limited
to by race and gender it should just be
that the joy of discovery again i
i just i suppose it helps but i i reject
it completely i've got a pretty
hard-line position on it um
but
yes there are violences out there i
would say very real violences if you
grow up in a neighborhood that is
plagued by street violence
uh that is a traumatic experience
now this is something i've also written
about which is crime and policing and
the solution for that is first
re-knit the family because it is it is
the breakdown it is a in a culture where
boys are not being socialized by
their fathers
and daniel patrick moynihan saw this in
1965
that is a culture that is going to head
towards anarchy
but absent
that the second best solution is
sound respectful constitutional policing
and that's what people that live in
those neighborhoods overwhelmingly want
in my experience i have spent lots of
time
in inner city police community meetings
and what i hear from those good
law-abiding bourgeois people is we want
more cops we want you to get the dealers
off the streets so there are very real
violences that are unequally distributed
that are hindrances of
getting to school
and and so society should obviously try
to eradicate them but
there has been no dearth
of big government projects
uh to try and redistribute wealth
and and and welfare that have not done a
whole lot
uh to close
the
racial divide
uh i think really what is needed now and
and again it there's been
no absence of trying we're in new york
city right now
we have a massive
government-supported social service
sector
that has a social worker for every ill
under the sun
what's really needed i would say now is
a rebirth of personal responsibility
i am happy that you're ending with that
because it is so crucial to embody that
feeling of
wanting to achieve success the personal
responsibility of taking a burden on
your shoulders of wanting to
become your own best potential and
teaching that to the children of the
next generations not that we need
a
that not that we need so many
assistance programs to help us but but
rather that we got to take a personal
responsibility up and at the same time
personal responsibility up and make it
easier for the baseline to be raised up
as well to remove the violence is in
place
um heather i want to see um let's let's
before we get to the final questions on
the way out
this
this foundation of truth
is what we've collectively learned as a
society over thousands of years of
evolution we've now propped up science
as a main foundation of truth
and i want to know what your thoughts
are on holding that integrity of that
foundation and also
how how that relates to what we can best
do moving forward with
having having civil discourses in
universities and corporations about how
to best bring on somebody that is
neurally diverse that their mind is
diverse and not by you know gonads and
melanin but by their thoughts
well i would disjunct diversity
completely as a
affirmative goal
neurodiversity mind diversity yeah i i
just think you look for the best
possible person i i now i've not worked
in a corporation
so it may be that
the criteria for
uh
admission for success for what you're
looking for are in fact very fuzzy
uh but where they're not where
you know pretty much who's a good
programmer or who's good at
doing spreadsheets or regression
analyses
uh
i think that's you look for that it's
it's not that complicated and
trying to seek
individuals by definition are different
there's no two people who are the same
to me every time somebody starts talking
about diversity it's code for something
else
uh you know interestingly the first
diversity officer that apple hired
got herself fired by saying at a
conference in bogota colombia that you
could have 24 white males in a room
and they would be diverse
because
individuals are diverse
this was so heretical
within the diversity ideology that says
that the only diversity that counts is
race and gender and that we should
typecast everybody that she was fired
for saying that and she of course
gruffled and apologized and said
uh well i just want to make sure that
nobody thinks that what i said is
representative of apple's views nor are
they of mine this is pathetic
she was right the first time around you
get 24
human beings together
and whatever their color and race
they're going to be different that same
principle can be applied to to 24 um
asian women or to 24 black men or
whatever yeah they're different they're
i'm not gonna stereotype somebody i know
liberal whites and conservative blacks
i know conservative whites and liberal
blacks
i'm not going to jump to any conclusions
about somebody based on their skin color
his on his skin color it i just it's
uh
it's it's an incredibly narrowing way of
viewing things
so
uh
you know i i would say excuse me that it
hurts our foundation of truth when we
start identity politics seeing
everything right absolutely and and
as far as their ability to find
truth about human nature going forward
you know we have now in in science
social sciences big replicability crisis
that is in part
due to the fact something that jonathan
hate has written about and again i
respect him and he's done very
powerfully
the overwhelming
uh ideological
monolith
in the social sciences that
is
he's concerned that it produces only one
way of seeing the world now i don't want
quotas for hiring conservatives in
academics i think that would be a
disaster i think any quota system is
inevitably stigmatizing
of the alleged beneficiaries
but but nevertheless
the
prioritization of race and gender
going forward is going to lead
generally it too is sort of a surrogate
and hand in hand with political bias and
i think we should just junk all of that
and the sort of last point before we get
to these final questions i think this is
a really important point
i wonder you know we're talking about
the diversity delusion
in the united states
which is so interesting because when you
extend this conversation to like what is
this like in china
right is are they even they think we're
crazy
i talked with asian physicists at
harvard when i was there doing a debate
on affirmative action and giving a talk
and
they just
the the the asian scientists and
students who are here
they cannot believe
what we're wasting our time upon
china is ruthlessly meritocratic the
asian countries all are ruthlessly
meritocratic yeah
a meritocracy right yeah based on how
strongly you perform in the field and
not your race and gender right right
yeah
and and i want you to continue telling
us about that story and i just i'm just
thinking about again running like what
is it
do they do they actually
go around and saying in india that well
we need to find white people to attend
the indian institute of technology and
in china we need to find white we need
to find black people to attend our
universities no they couldn't care less
they are you know
whoever's the best and to a certain
extent of course nationalistic
but um yeah
you know the best thing that trump would
could do to level the playing field with
china is to airlift a few cargo planes
of gender feminists from american
universities and dump them on beijing
university and its research labs because
as long as they remain uninfected
by this identity poison
they will pull out ahead
uh they care only about one thing are
you the best person to
unlock the the secrets of the human
genome you know and and they're
going ahead in a perhaps unethical way
with their genetic splicing and whatnot
uh and so they have some problems with
the integrity possibly the research but
they are still
seeking the smartest genetic engineers
they can get
i'm happy you're talking about it again
just that you've got to be at the
cutting edge of knowledge the cutting
edge of science cutting edge of
technology and not caring so much about
race and gender but rather how well do
you know the genome how well do you know
how to program artificial intelligence
how well do you know how to
program blockchain protocols how well do
you know these things because this is
how old do you know how the brain works
because those are the people that no
matter what the race and gender is
they're at the cutting edge of knowledge
and we're not going oh they're black or
they're white or they're purple it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter they're
at the cutting edge of knowledge and we
need to push the boundaries of the
cutting edge of knowledge and help
children get to those cutting edges of
knowledge regardless of their race and
gender just help them get to those edges
wherever they care about going
um i'm glad we ran that experiment of
what it's like in other places in the
world
that what is it like for their diversity
conversations in other places in the
world why are we so obsessed with a
diversity conversation here where
there's so much more based on
meritocracy everywhere else um
okay heather um
before we get to those last questions is
there another
pressing point that you think we should
cover in the conversation
um
no i guess i would just say that
universities should be places where
students encounter beauty and greatness
where the faculty
teach them why they should be down on
their knees in gratitude before
works of sublime insight
and imagination that take
us out of our petty narrow selves
into worlds that we would otherwise
never experience whether it's life on a
19th century russian feudal estate
or into the
imaginary groves of pastoral poetry
or experiencing the langer of a chopin
nocturne
these are all things that
enrich us and again
take us out of the present
education should be about the
transmission of an of an inheritance
from one generation to the next
and all too often now it's about the
transmission
of
ungrounded unjustified anger resentment
and self-pity
how can we pass along the best
collective learning principles to the
next generation over and over again
because that's how to prosper most
effectively
well we do it by
throwing aside anger resentment
grievance
and
opening ourselves to beauty
yeah
because it's a miracle that we're here
on earth it's a miracle that we have all
this ubiquity around us so yeah
okay
the couple questions on the way out we
like to ask our guests what would you
say is a core driving principle of yours
well
meritocracy and
a belief in the humanistic tradition a
sorrow and a rage that
that humanistic learning is being
destroyed
uh
a feeling that
it's on us to keep these great books
alive if we stop reading them they die
so
just a sense of urgency
about keeping
the
inheritance of civilization
vital
and available to everybody uh who should
who has the privilege to to absorb it
and also i guess a contempt for idiocy i
don't like
i i just uh
you know explanations of reality that
are clearly counterfactual
i have no patience for
and
what would you
if you could rebuild
civilization from scratch
how would you design it
well
i you know i'm i'm not a deep hayeki and
uh friedrich hayek but
i i know enough about him that i would
say that
one doesn't design such things they
evolve organically
uh
and so
i'm i'm sort of agnostic about that but
it seems right to me so i think that
any individual
is going to have a hard time
uh
constructing a civilization you know
it's it's it's
derived by trial and error empirically i
guess what i would do would be to try
and
stop the wrong turn
that i think
started to happen partly as a result of
the enormous success of capitalism in
the 1950s where you had adolescents for
the first time ever in human history
being
themselves
autonomous consumers and thus the target
of corporations because they now had
buying power because
america was so fantastically wealthy
that teenagers were liberated
through the car and through having huge
pocket change and so we got the growth
of youth culture
which is stupid culture by and large
uh a reversal of traditional hierarchies
where adults are
viewed as the
source of
instruction and discipline and you had
children broken free and and being given
more
say in things and that's
children or children you know
adolescents have adolescent tastes they
don't know very much
but that
part of that
capitalism capitalist success
gave us the 1960s counter culture
and its trashing
of so much of western civilization so i
i would
maybe sort of
reconfigure things a little bit there
how you would do so
i don't know but i would fight back
harder
against the pretensions of
the counterculture and the hippies and
the whole revolution now
i would not obviously fight the civil
rights revolution that struggle that was
absolutely needed
but
i think that
the
what's called the hermeneutics of
suspicion
the assumption that any kind of
existing structure is simply a mask for
oppression
and and unfairness i i disagree with
that view and i would i would try and un
undo that totally it's been a
a hierarchy of competence is a really
good way to look at things and that's
right yep yep
um okay how about do you think this is a
simulation
reality do i think it's a simulation
of something else
uh no i think it's all we've got
i think that uh
we are
living in a real physical environment
and uh
we die
uh and
everything is mortal the transience is
is the nature of
of our reality including probably the
universe
so
uh i
but i i do think that you stub your toe
on a rock and that rock is real
and the last question is what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world
music
you have a massive grand piano yeah i
think
mozart's operas
the saint matthew passion by bach
chopin brahms i
schubert i mean one is drowning in
beauty
and tell us about why
those musical
pieces
are the most beautiful thing for you
well they
they contain a pathos
they lift one up into a sense of
grandeur and nobility
they
contain sorrow eroticism
desire
of
exuberance
and
they
are able to express things
that
feelings
and
states of being that no other
medium of expression can
love it i love it and i really love
listening to those composers it's
million pieces of work
um
heather this has been such a pleasure
thank you pleasure talking to you alex
thank you for coming on to the show
again get my frozen hand out it smells
so warm
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it um check out the
links below to heather's work also the
diversity delusion is also in the links
below go and check it out
really do some thought experiments in
our minds about that foundation of
scientific truth and how we want to keep
building the world on that and what
people around the world are thinking
about uh how we're handling diversity
and do they even have diversity there
etc so really we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know
what your thoughts are also
go and um go and build the future
everyone manifest your own destiny into
the world build create
and
we'll see you soon thanks everyone for
tuning in keep supporting simulation so
we can continue doing cool things like
coming on site to a great place like new
york and talking awesome people like
heather and thank you everyone we'll see
you soon bye